Oh tonight we're gonna talk about
concurrency we're gonna talk about a
sink and a weight as a sort of modern
approach to doing concurrency in
JavaScript and I'm Simon so I'm a
JavaScript and react engineer I've been
been doing JavaScript for a long time
and react for a number of years now I
have a have a team in just outside of
Jakarta
code fox is our company and so you can
also find me on twitter with SST you are
underscore so today we're going to talk
about concurrency and it's kind of a
technical topic so I'll try to explain
it as simply as I can and but you're
definitely gonna see some code so we're
gonna go through some code and talk
about some concepts does maybe we should
start with who is it is everybody a
JavaScript programmer or does write
JavaScript in here okay cool just
checking and so like and what about like
using kind of more modern es6 constructs
is everybody using es6 at least has some
familiarity with that yeah okay cool cuz
just because that's what the the code
slides that we're gonna look at is all
es6 so so let's talk about what is
concurrency so concurrency is doing
multiple tasks in a period of time right
so typically one core can only do one
thing at once as well as other other
pieces of hardware can only do a single
thing at a time but over it over a
stretch of time we want to do multiple
things right so a web server wants to
serve multiple requests for a web page a
script wants to read multiple values
from a database before it returns the
request and so so what we're really
talking about is doing multiple tasks
over over a period of time and some of
those things we can do in parallel and
some things we have to do one at a time
and so generally order dependent or
partially ordered units oh sorry order
independent or partially ordered units
of work is where concurrency happens so
this is just an example of like multiple
tasks that may start at various
different
times but are kind of running over the
same period of time right so they're
running in parallel essentially some of
these are right and so this is this is
something that is is pretty hard to do
in computing right in in particular it's
hard to reason about it's hard to it
leads to race conditions it leads to
difficult models of things changing over
time right
and so concurrency is specifically
important when we're dealing with user
input
I'm sorry input/output is in like
network requests also user input users
interacting with the system and reading
writing from disks anything that is kind
of considered a synchronous type of
activity right something where the CPU
needs to stop and wait for the user to
do something or the CPU needs to stop
and wait for some data to arrive from
the database or the network right and so
there's typically two ways for a program
to do those kind of tasks right so to do
i/o specifically we have the blocking or
the synchronous style which is it's easy
to write it's what PHP and Ruby and
Python and most web especially
server-side technologies are doing
synchronous or blocking i/o right and
that's and in order for that to work we
need multi-threading because if we stop
one thread we need another thread to be
able to continue to serve user requests
right and so but it's easy to write
because you write everything
sequentially however there's a memory
overhead to that because every thread
requires memory and there's context
switching so when the CPU switches
between the threads right so there's
overhead there the other sort of
paradigm the other pattern is the non
blocking or the event loop style and so
that's single threaded so everything
runs in one thread which means we cannot
block the thread we do get high
concurrency and we at low memory so
that's the win and it's really good for
UI so user interactions stuff right
that's why the browser uses the event
loop pattern and it's also good for i/o
bound services things that are doing a
lot of reading from network or database
or
but it's not great for things that are
cpu-bound right because anything that's
using the CPU is is blocking other
things that can be happening so that's
kind of the the overview of the two
patterns and so JavaScript as you know
is the second one and so all the
browsers and and most JavaScript
server-side frameworks are all
event-driven or non blocking there are
some exceptions to that like
historically like really older engines
but in general every JavaScript you ever
write will be event-driven non blocking
so you might have any questions about
that stuff so so what happens if you
block in JavaScript well there are some
things that will block the thread right
that will halt any other execution and
so alert right is the most common alert
or prompt and so we also have a
synchronous style of XML HTTP requests
and it's it's rare because that was
probably a mistake in the API they
probably did not intend for that to be
synchronous or at least it wasn't a good
idea and then we have some stuff in node
world that are intentionally synchronous
for various reasons but I think the one
that everybody's probably familiar with
is the sort of alert style where it
blocks everything else that's happening
and so that's this one right and so
that's like the page puts a dialogue up
and everything pauses right you cannot
interact or press a button you can't
even scroll and so that's kind of a bad
user experience right and so that's what
we mean when we say a blocking
interaction or blocking the thread so
how do we write concurrent software
without blocking so generally in
JavaScript world as you know we use
callbacks right and it's it's pretty
straightforward we just pass a function
and when the task is finished JavaScript
will call our function and that would be
for instance an on-click event so you
pass a function to the to the document
to the browser and whenever a user
clicks a button then your callback gets
it's executed similarly a network
request right you you're waiting for the
network requests to finish and then the
callback happens so this is the callback
style all right we're gonna read a file
this is more maybe server-side we read a
file and the files finish reading we
have our content so does everybody
understand the callback style I mean
that's pretty much every every
JavaScript program you've written right
so what's the good days it's a good low
level abstraction for concurrency for
asynchronous actions it performs really
well it has low overhead there's not
context switching involved and we can do
almost any asynchronous tasks using
callbacks right
what's the downsides well doing things
in callback style is really difficult
right so doing things in sequence is
difficult doing things in parallel is
even harder
you give up your constructs that you're
familiar with like for and while and try
catch and those are things that people
come to JavaScript world from PHP
background or from Java or from any
almost any other language and they don't
understand why you can't do these things
right and so error handling right as you
know you always have to check this error
parameter things could fail during the
middle of a network request it needs to
be handled and your code readability
goes downhill pretty fast so systems
become kind of hard to maintain when
there's a lot of callback asynchronous
code and so this is kind of the example
of the first one which is like the or
sorry they're giving up the constructs
that programmers are familiar with right
this is your typical example right so
it's like every day on Stack Overflow
somebody asks what's wrong with this
code right and does everybody can
anybody see why this code will not do
what the programmer will expects right
so here we're defining an empty variable
and here we're returning an empty
variable and then somewhere later that
variable will be set after the networker
guest comes back
but to a programmer from a non
asynchronous world this is a strange
thing right this is a strange thing and
so that's why and that's why I like
people new to JavaScript are always on
Stack Overflow asking this question
right so you know callbacks they add
complexity it's messy to chain them
right if you need to do three things in
a row simple things right like like
write something to the console wait a
second write another thing to the
console wait another second and write
something to the console that's like a
lot of callbacks right so it's so it
becomes messy to chain things and it's
pretty hard to do things at the same
time and so this is your sequential
stuff and so this might be the most code
you see on any slide but but I want you
to get the idea of how the complexity
grows when you're using this style right
and we're not even doing any error
checking here right this is like the
simplified version this is just taking
three files and we just want to total
the number of bytes in those files so we
have to read three things from disk
right so we're gonna so we're gonna stat
file one add it to the data size to the
total stat file to add the size to the
total and do the same thing with number
three every time we're getting more
indented and then eventually we have our
total and we can do our callback right
and so is anybody written code like this
all the time right so if we want to do
so these three things these three files
we don't have to do them one by one
right we can just read all the files and
then get the total number of bytes so if
we want to do it in parallel it's a
little harder right so this is kind of
my naive version with no error handling
of doing the same three files in
parallel so here we we put the files in
an array with four each and we stat each
file individually right the problem is
how do we know when we're done because
they might the the answer might come
back in any order so we have to keep
track of the number that are finished
and we got a count every time one
finishes we got to add that number and
when we've reached three then we know
we're done right so this is kind of
parallelism in
whole back world right and then there's
air handling so which we didn't even
look at yet right so what do you do like
we spend a lot of effort just just
checking if there's an error when we've
read file one but file two has already
completed successfully how do we handle
that and if we look at the same example
with air handling it doesn't even fit on
a slide right because now we have to
like if there's an error we need to log
it and return and that's not even good
error handling like that's the minimum
error handling just a log the error and
just give up right and so we have to do
it every time and so we have readability
issues so when when readability is this
bad you know systems become difficult to
maintain a difficult to read it's easy
for sort of like errors and bugs in your
code just to sneak in so so let's talk
about promises so we've kind of talked
about call backs right so promises do a
little better so this is basically a
thin wrapper a thin abstraction around
call backs and so it gives us the
chaining that we need you know doing
tasks one waiting till it finishes doing
task two and continuing in sequential
order it gives us helpers to do things
in parallel it gives us error handling
and there composable right because the
way a promise works is we can pass
around a representation of a future
value right so a promise is an object
that represents what the value will be
when the operation finishes and so it
kind of looks like this so we read a
file and then we get two things we get
then and catch so we can so then we can
in a sense attach a handler or a
callback that gets executed whenever the
data is finished so it's better than
callbacks like it it may not seem so at
first it may seem more complicated but
it is better and so it looks if you look
at this code like all we did was take
our callback and put it in
then right but we still have our call
back but it's better because we can
because we can do some chaining with
that and so I'll give you an example
with so this is so this is a very simple
function that uses set timeout and it
just waits for 1000 milliseconds for one
second and then it fulfills the promise
right so it's the same idea as a set
timeout but in promise world so so the
idea is that here we want to just wait
one second and log something and wait
another second and log another thing and
so we don't want all of that nested
callbacks so we we get a better more
readable pattern here right so at least
we can see first we sleep then we do
this thing and then we do this other
thing and then lastly we do this this
final thing so at least it reads in a
very sequential order and so the first
thing you might notice is that we're
returning something from inside our our
callback right so inside of our event
handler we're returning another promise
so remember whenever we call sleep it
returns a promise that will fulfill or
will finish in the future resolve it
will resolve in the future and so when
we return to promise from in here that's
what allows us to call another then and
then the last one we didn't return
anything so we're finished right so even
this right might be a little better than
callbacks but you know it's not amazing
but we get flow control so when we go
back to our example of doing certain
things that we have to do in series we
have to wait for one to finish and then
do the next other things we want to do
in parallel at the same time and so
that's really hard with call backs but
it's easier with promises so the example
would be we want to fetch some data
about maybe the user that's logged in
right now and then we're gonna get back
we're going to get back this user object
and then we want to fetch the friends of
that user and then we'll return that
promise right so every time we call
fetch JSON we're gonna get this promise
and so we'll return that promise and
then when that finishes we have the IDS
of all the friends and so now and and
this is where it becomes powerful is now
we can take these IDs and we map through
them so we so we go through each
individual friend ID and we want to
fetch the user details of that friend
and what I do here is I actually create
an array of promises so each time for
each ID we return a new promise and
since we're calling a radar map we get a
map we get an array of promises and then
we can call promise that all which just
waits for them all to finish gets all
the results and we can return that
promise and then when we're finally
finished our last then we have like all
of the details for all of the friends in
the order that they were provided in the
same order that they were in this array
so promise that all is the magic that I
wanted to understand from this slide so
here we're doing something that would be
really hard in callback world because
we're doing the first two things in
sequence right
they have like we can't get the friends
until we get the user right so we have
to do some things in sequence but other
things we can do in parallel so so
that's the power of control flow with
promises so promises even though they
don't seem great at first or at least
when I first learned them it seemed like
a not much better than callback so once
you explore the chaining and the control
flow it is better so error handling we
get a catch and so we don't have to
check every single time for this error
we can just attach one one catch
function at the end
and so exceptions will bubble through
our code or bubble up the way we expect
it to work in normal programming with
try-catch so in this case if we go back
to our same user profiles example I can
just add one catch at the very end and
grab that error and we just know an
error happens somewhere in one of these
and error happened all right everybody
with me so far
cool but we're still putting callbacks
inside of then right I mean we're still
doing callbacks it's a nicer way to do
callbacks but ultimately we eventually
have to have to pass these functions so
can we do better so what do we want to
do like we want to just like have normal
sequential programming like we're used
to in other languages and so here's what
we want right we want we want to get our
promise we want to somehow wait for the
promise to finish and then we just want
to log the result right with no then
anywhere and so the problem is
javascript is fundamentally
single-threaded so we can't block and
what I mean by that is we can't just
pause the program right here wait for
the promise to finish and then resume
because we don't want to block our
entire thread and then you have the same
problem as when you use alert and then
the whole software is just not doing
anything useful so javascript is single
threaded we can't block however there's
a special thing called a generator
function and so what that is is that
allows us to pause just one function and
we'll go back to it later so we're not
gonna pause our whole program we'll just
pause this function and so as anybody
used or seen this generator syntax with
the with the star so that's the special
thing right here is the star and then
the keyword yield so generators are
generators are not about asynchronous or
event loops or they're not about
they're not about doing concurrence the
concurrency they're just about pausing
stuff basically right so we get this
thing called yield we can just wait so
the idea is we just pause the execution
of just this function we wait for
something and then later we will be
resumed and we just console dot log the
string that says we're back whenever
somebody has resumed us so there needs
to be something controlling this some
function needs to needs to resume this
whenever the whenever the fetch has
completed so generators are pretty
complex and I don't want to spend a lot
of time on them I just want you to know
that generator is the only thing that
kind of allows this to work because we
can pause our function and it's and it's
important to understand it just pauses
this function not everything so we take
promises we combine it with generators
and we get awesome stuff so this is the
this is the whole the whole point we get
a single wait so it's basically just a
layer of syntax on top of generators and
promises and it looks like this so
instead of a function star we have this
async function but it's really similar
to that function star right we use the
word a wait and we put a promise after
that so a wait and then a promise and it
always has to be that way and then what
that does is that a way we'll pause it
in the middle of in the middle of
executing this line we just pause the
whole function and we just wait but we
you know we let the we'd let the event
loop do other stuff and then eventually
when this fetch has completed this
function gets resumed and then we have
our results and now we can just console
dot log the results so this is the whole
idea of a single way to things remember
you can only use a way inside of an
async
and it has to work with promises so it's
a win it's a win because we get back our
traditional constructs right we get back
our for a while or try catch it becomes
readable I mean it's got its got some
keywords in there that might seem
strange at first but but it flows like
normal programming in any other language
and normal thread blocking programming
right and we get this kind of interrupts
with promises so we can use any other
promise library and use it with a single
way because it just uses promises so the
same example or a new example of reading
a file here with async/await is that
here we just use this read file which is
a function that we've kind of made up
that presumably just returns a promise
and then we just wait for that and we
get our content and then we convert it
to a string we parse it with JSON and we
log the result so it's so it's it just
reads sequentially like you'd expect and
and the point of this slide is that now
we have our try catch back so two things
could go wrong here
right something could go wrong with the
reading of the file the file doesn't
exist the the USB stick has been
unplugged the permissions aren't there
so this thing could fail the other thing
that could go wrong is parse there was
invalid JSON it just it doesn't the the
JSON dot parse can't handle what the
file had in it so these two things could
have gone wrong and so this thing is
going wrong in async world right
something is happening asynchronously
while our function is paused but this
exception is just a traditional normal
regular JavaScript exception
and async await doesn't care the try
will work exactly how you expect it to
and and it will it will send the error
to your catch no matter which problem
happened so we can kind of not really
think about async callback errors be
different from any other error and so we
also get back our for loop right things
that are just normal programming
constructs that have been around since
the 70s and we understand them and so in
this case we're combining just a regular
for loop with async/await
and we get something really cool so in
this case we just take a regular browser
element and we're gonna loop through a
hundred times and move it a little bit
to the right
by increasing the left value by one
pixel every time we're just gonna
increase it to the right but we we want
to do it every frame right it's an
animation we want to wait in between the
frames and so we're gonna wait 16
milliseconds between every between every
adjustment of the of the value of the
style so in this case in like four lines
we've written in an animation with a
hundred frames that happen 60 frames a
second that would be really difficult to
do with callbacks but because async
await just pauses our function in the
middle of a loop it just does what we
kind of expect it to do and it's
understandable anybody have any
questions about this so it's just
promises an async function itself
returns a promise and so when we await a
promise our function pauses until the
promise is already or until it's
resolved
so we can still use our normal promised
stuff right so promised out all which we
talked about earlier
it still works with with async/await and
here's an example of that so here we're
gonna fetch our we're gonna get our user
and we're gonna get our friends and then
we're gonna map over our friends and
create our array of promises just like
before but in this case we're using a
wait for both of the first things
because we can't do the second thing
until we finished with the first thing
right so we have to wait on those but
these promises that the fetching the
friends we can do those all at the same
time so we just create an array of
promises just like before we call
promised at all and then we await that
so we await them all to be done so we
just so we as long as the thing on the
right of the await word is a promise
everything's cool so the thing on the
right needs to be a promise and then and
then we console dot log it at the end
but the thing I want you to know about
this is that this whole entire function
because it has this async word itself
returns a promise right so if I call the
function get user friends if I call this
function it returns a promise
yes yes you can you can await another
async function because it's just
promises so a few pro tips don't forget
to use your await
if you accidentally leave out this word
because you're so you're so excited that
everything is like you know normal
programming again that you kind of
forget to leave out the await it's not
gonna do what you think it does so don't
forget your await be careful about doing
too many things in sequence if you can
actually do them in parallel so now that
we have our four loops back that we love
it's very tempting to just put a weight
inside of a for loop and we have to
remember that if we do that it's gonna
pause that for loop every single
iteration so don't do too much in
sequence if you can do it in parallel
and so the other thing is that using a
weight in a map or filter function
probably doesn't do what you expect and
so I should show you an example of that
but the idea is that a filter function
right a radar filter should take a
function that returns a boolean but if
you pass an async function it's gonna
return a promise and so probably not
gonna do what you think it does so you
just have to remember that so map it's
fine to use but just remember that if
you pass an async function into map
you're gonna get an array of promises
which might be what you want and so even
though it looks synchronous also
remember that your code has been paused
and then started again later so some of
the assumptions that you might make
about global state or global variables
might no longer be true after your
function has been resumed because things
have changed in the world while you were
paused so user input right it's been
traditionally hard with nodejs if you've
ever written a CLI tool you need to read
some data from the user and then you
gotta have a call back and then you got
to read more data from a user and it
becomes really
nested and so this is just our final
example it's just that we can just
create a read line function that returns
a promise and we can now await it and
write command line programs just like
you wouldn't Python or any other
language but we get all the advantages
of note as well so you can use this
today async/await is in chrome it's in
Firefox and it's a node for any of the
other browsers you should use Babel but
but it's actually not that bad to use
Babel because async/await is a pretty
thin layer on top of just generators and
promises so most browsers support
generators anyway so there's not too
much stuff that Babel needs to do to
make this work so thanks for listening